-It's always great to see you.
We met in this building.
-Yes, we did.
-In 2001.
And you have had a --
Your acting career has thrived
Mine came to a dead end.
But we did --
We did act together
in one of the finest sketche
that ever aired on "SNL."
-Absolutely.
-Yeah.
-The "Fenced-In Area."
-"Fenced-In Area."
We actually talked about
this sketch just last week
with the writer of it,
Emily Spivey, who was here
And this a sketch -- You playe
a simple man in this sketch.
-I did. Yes.
-You just had a fenced-in area
And you were trying
to figure out what do with it.
-That's all I wanted to know
I just -- I had the space.
I had the chain link.
And I wanted to do
something important with it.
[ Laughter ]
-And you still get --
People still come up to yo
about "Fenced-In Area."
-It's the weirdest thing.
[ Laughter ]
-I will confirm
that's a weird thing, yeah
-Right? And that's like
nearly 20 years ago.
And one skit
on "Saturday Night Live."
-Yeah.
-And people still, you know --
Somebody will come up to me,
and I'll go, "Okay, here we go."
[ Laughter ]
It's going to be, you know
"I loved 'Armageddon.'"
"I love 'Sling Blade.'"
I love whatever.
"Oh, my God. 'Monster's Ball.'
And they come up, and they go,
"Dude, 'Fenced-In Area'?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
-This is a great show.
"Goliath" is a great show.
Third season. You take --
You play an alcoholic lawyer who
takes on wealthy corporations.
One of the great things
about it --
Wonderful foils against you.
William Hurt.
Dennis Quaid this season.
Mark Duplass. Morris Chestnut.
Do you enjoy this character?
It seems like
it's a pretty meaty part.
-I love it. I mean, it's
probably closer to myself --
I mean, not that I'm
an alcoholic lawyer.
But I --
[ Laughter ]
-No one thinks you're a lawyer
Billy Bob.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-So, yeah.
But, I mean, it's kind of like
I just go to work every da
and do what I would do
if I were that guy.
And after a while,
after you play a character
for a couple of seasons
on something,
you start to feel like
the stuff's actually happening
to you. You know?
-Yeah.
-I mean, you do.
You get to work.
You're in this scene.
And it's like, "Oh, really?"
And Dennis Quaid, you know
he's my old buddy.
You know, we've been running
buddies for probably 25 years.
And it was great
having him on there because,
you know, we -- You get busy
in the entertainment business,
you know,
and you don't see each other
We live like 1/2 mile
from each other.
But then we were
working together,
so I got to see him every day.
And they made the huge mistake
of putting our trailers
next to each other.
-Yeah.
-And there was a lot of,
"Has anybody seen Billy
or Dennis?" going on.
Yeah. So --
-You have had trouble
with the law, run-ins,
but at a very young age,
growing up in Arkansas,
the FBI,
did they raid your house?
-It was my grandmother's house
-Okay.
Why did the FBI raid
your grandmother's house?
-Well, I was --
See, I was only like 3.
You got to understand, or 4.
-Okay. Gotcha.
-I was a little kid.
My uncle, my mom's brother
he was kind of a --
He was a traveling
country musician kind of guy
part-time carpenter.
[ Laughter ]
And he always had
these weird friends
he would bring home from Texas
And this guy came home
with him one time
and, you know, sort of
like a con artist,
you know, smooth talker.
-Sure.
-And a bunch of us lived
at my grandmother's house.
We were very poor,
so we all lived there --
like, cousins and aunts an
uncles, all in this one house.
And this guy was just ther
with my uncle.
And suddenly he stayed
for like a month.
And then one day,
the FBI just came in there
and carted him off.
And turns out he was really fond
of stealing
other people's vehicles
and taking them
across state lines.
And my grandfather, who wa
kind of like Daniel Boone,
had killed a giant turtle,
and he was making turtle soup.
And he was one of those guys -
He was a medic in World War I,
so he'd seen everything,
you know?
And he's standing there
cleaning this turtle
to make turtle soup.
And an FBI guy
comes to the back door.
And my grandfather said, "Di
you ever see a turtle that big?"
You know?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That is --
That's a guy
who keeps your cool.
-Yeah.
-Keeps his cool.